we're we're talking a lot about you know
there's lockdowns and
and a few minutes ago we were talking
about what you're allowed to know and so
reminding me of the story i want to pull
this up and get your guys comments on it
it's from this from sarahcarter.com
sarah carter show
cnn segment discusses removing
conservative media and forcing everyone
into the quote
same conceptual reality in this segment
with brian stelton reliable sources
a former facebook i think i think as a
facebook executive says that they need
to basically treat conservatives like
they did isis
and start isolating and removing them my
favorite
my favorite quote is when this guy says
there are people on youtube for example
that have a larger audience than daytime
cnn
huh that's right there's actually a ton
of youtube channels
it sounds like eliminating the
competition it doesn't exactly yeah
exactly it's funny i'm pretty sure
the overwhelming majority of career
youtube channels get better ratings than
cnn
like i'm sure okay there's there's a lot
of small youtube channels
but if you have oh geez if you have a
couple hundred thousand subscribers on
youtube
you're probably doing better than cnn in
the key demo right and if you're if
you're a channel with a million subs or
more you're definitely
so it's basically every single channel
i'm i'm pretty sure like kyle kalinski
jimmy and david pakman are beating
cnn but cnn's not targeting the left
channels
they're targeting the right wing
channels cnn staff cnn
uh i don't want to call the guy a
reporter oh in a resident
extremist zealot oliver darcy is
reaching out to
cable providers to get fox news on and
newsmax banned
from their networks from their from from
the cable subscriptions you can't even
buy it they want to get pulled
it's a whole new level of lunacy
and censorship because they're not going
to stop at twitter right we
project veritas put out this video clip
where we can see they're talking about
banning more and more people
they're not going to stop there because
their bread and butter is
screaming in your face that's what they
do
i love how they used to rag on fox news
saying fox news was just scaring old
people
well i tell you what cnn does college
kids yeah
when i turn on cnn you know the only
thing i imagine is
don lemon going oh and brian said
they're like
that's the whole thing and i'm like just
sitting there going like ah that's
that's what cnn is
and so what happens when they've already
banned everybody right
so they say they banned 70 000 q anon
related individuals
they banned donald trump uh-oh what's
oliver darcy gonna do
be out of a job they already fired jim
acosta he's no longer at the white house
anymore
he's doing beat reporting now i guess so
uh
oliver doctor says fox news let's get
them banned
and they won't stop they'll keep going
eventually some powerful people are
losing money and maybe then they'll wake
up and realize what's going on i gotta
say
when we were when we i guess you could
say the us government removed a
segment of the bath party of of
hussein's iraqi
cabinet and hundreds i don't even
thousands of people were removed from
the workforce and not allowed to work
that caused the formation of isis when
you remove people from the workforce and
won't allow them to enter it
they will form a new organization and
those people in iraq got violent
so i get that they're trying to go after
preventing isis but if they
if they do this and they ban all these
people there's a chance that
that we're going to create something
like isis in the united states ian hold
on
from the washington times trump
supporters likened to nazis and saddam's
bath party
in cable news demon is demonization duel
cuomo and don lemon they're they're
talking exactly
read history and understand the
formation of isis you know what
it it seems to me that this is kind of
what they want though
they they want to keep pushing people
until they can they can make them do
something radical so they're essentially
radicalizing people they're pushing them
pushing them pushing and pushing them
they're not giving them any any remedy
to these to these oppressive measures
and then
eventually like you said if you remove
people you're going to create this
vacuum where something else forms and
and
usually in that in in that case is
something ugly
and you're going to start to radicalize
people but that's i i call me crazy but
then you get your hey they're domestic
terrorists well these angry people here
they're domestic terrorists now
now we need to get them out that's what
isis was there's another created
and then we had something to fight
there's another way to look at it it's
not that the people are being
radicalized it's that oliver darcy
is radicalized okay so again for those
that have heard me talk about my other
channels
darcy interviewed me several years ago
when i said banning the alt-right for
their opinions is dangerous free speech
means even the speech we don't like
this guy working for business insider
was like what an interesting thought i
should highlight this for a story
where am i today four years later same
exact position
i have not moved i still believe in free
speech even for speech i don't like
and i'll argue against it but the only
difference let it be spoken
where has he gone since that that four
years ago when he interviewed me he's
now the
cheerleader most high profile like the
highest profile
activist extremist trying to get
private companies that can do whatever
they want to ban
access to certain news channels he
doesn't like so it's not that the people
in the middle have become extreme it's
that oliver darcy shot so far left
from his point of view there's a bunch
of far-right extremists
far right from him and he's he's too
radicalized to realize that he's the one
who's been pushed to the extreme
yeah well exactly the they're they're
taking a hard left
and and in doing so these people that
are regular
normal everyday people who fall moderate
right or even moderate left
now in in order to defend your position
right because in in politics we always
tend to compromise
in order to defend that position they
have to
pull hard to the right or they're going
to lose ground you know because if you
start compromising with
somebody who's going far left and you're
still
arguing the middle road you're gonna
wind up that's what's happening
you're gonna wind up there unless you
you start to
pull back harder yeah and it's but
what's happening is that
conservatives and moderates regular
americans
aren't becoming extreme they're they're
in fact policing the extremes of the
right
they are you look at uh steve king when
he made comments about what positive
comments about white nationalism they
pulled him off all his committees
and then he got primaried in the by the
republican party and he's out
and now because the republicans were
like we don't want none of that
and the moderates are like all right
that's cool the left doesn't do that
so they don't so as long as
conservatives keep trying to be
reasonable and play by the rules and the
left won't
you're always you're always going to
lose ground you're kind of like a
leftist that's
trying to keep the left from going crazy
right
well well i would just i would disagree
with you tim i think oliver darcy is
doing
god's work i think all all information
should be conformed and unified by
special interest talking points by the
richest people in our society who know
what's best for us
and i think it's great that they already
on youtube are promoted an algorithm
when you search news you see them first
the next video that usually plays is
them
whatever you're watching i think it's
great that they have this unfair market
competition since they know what's best
for you and where would we all be
if it wasn't for cnn's top article today
on cnn politics
about i'm not kidding you this is this
is the headline here
cnn released an article saying this is
joe biden's
inauguration party playlist that you're
gonna play
oh my god for your inauguration yeah i
didn't listen though
yeah they're literally releasing the
playlist
for you to celebrate joe biden's give me
a couple of
what were they what i didn't know we
could find a way i don't know about the
one you had from today but i do have joe
biden and kamal harris drop a playlist
for your inauguration watch party
that's it yeah where would we be if we
didn't have hard-hitting
real news like this uh that's forced
jammed down our throats where
hold on hold don't you want to be lulled
into a calming ignorant
sleep yes i want to play my music and
celebrate
the poor old man who doesn't know where
he is he's represented by all the
special women
this is bliss it's bliss yeah you know
listen listen let me ask you a question
if there was a meteor or a comet or
whatever about to rip through the earth
and just
wipe it out no no no that's too quick
let's say it's like a it's like a giant
it's an asteroid or meteor about to hit
the earth
and when it does burst into flames
and you'll have three minutes left to
live as you watch the fireball
coming towards you would you rather
watch
and know it's happening or would you
rather be chilling in your basement
headphones on playing skyrim or
something
no i want to get it i want to i
[Music]
i crack a beer and just be like maybe
the sd card will survive
that's kind of how i'm going to watch
the inauguration actually
staring at the sunset like it's the end
yes
no but i mean look a lot of people would
prefer to be in the basement headphones
on
playing through games totally ignorant
to the world collapsing around them and
just be vaporized instantly
there's a lot of people not me i'm not
one it's almost like it's like you know
in the matrix you know which pill
do you want a lot of people would be
like nah i'm gonna take the blue pill
i don't want to i can't do the head in
the same thing it's part of why this
this covet in the food supply thing is
driving me insane because i think that
it's it's a hard cognitive dissonance
for people to think that maybe the the
animal fat that they're eating the meat
and the cheese and the
the cream the milk is going to contain
that stuff or hyper
exacerbate its growth in your system and
dear god don't stick your head in the
sand it's right in front of us
yeah well they want to keep you afraid
they want to keep you in a state where
you're at a low vibrational kind of
energetic field where you're
always panicking always freaking out and
and when you're in that kind of highly
emotional state you're very easily to be
manipulated you're very easily able to
be controlled by other people coming in
and saying
i have the perfect solution i'll keep
you safe look how strong i am look how
many national guardsmen i have behind me
i know it's better for you if you just
give me everything you have
and that's exactly what's happening
right now with this latest move by joe
biden blocking people from traveling
there's going to be more blocking
there's going to be more lockdowns and
there's going to be more division pushed
on by the mainstream media that wants to
keep you in this fierce state of
the average common man they want you
afraid of your neighbor
and another thing that i wanted to
address when you guys were talking
before
about this larger division issue the
washington post
literally released a piece about
multi-racial whiteness
trying to explain how people of color
voted for and supported donald trump
enrique from
the proud boys as the photos they're
making up new terms
to represent whiteness which is again
just in their lexicon
right now that they use as a little
pinata that they beat the crap
out of since they get candy out of
because so many few people
are afraid to stand up for each other
and they're getting away with this
essentially because of our acquiescence
and our participation in the fear and
hatred of one another
what's so what's so insidious about that
article
is that what they're doing with saying
multiracial whiteness
is that whiteness represents negative
traits of people
which has been going on for a long time
it's been going on for a long time but
what they're doing is they're saying
these negative behaviors are inherent to
white people
and non-white people can have these
behaviors too you see what they're doing
they're basically they're not saying
that people are white they're saying
whiteness
is is just a word that represents bad
right
exactly so so there you go supremacy
white supremacy all that stupid nonsense
which makes no sense especially when you
see the boogaloo boys
there's a video of these people in dc i
think it's in dc i'm not sure
no maybe maybe it's richmond and they're
talking to boogaloo boys and they're
like
you were you were with white
supremacists and they're like no we're
not we've never been like yeah
you were down there in dc during the six
and they're like no we weren't
they were boogaloo boys they're wearing
hawaiian shirts and they're like that's
not us which there was what two million
people in dc
was every single one of those at white
supremacists yes you know because i was
there and i saw
saw a lot of multi-racial whiteness down
there and it's
that's that like
who who who reads that and actually
looks at that and says yeah yeah really
really this is this is hard hitting hard
hitting drama
i'm afraid like corey bush i gotta meet
her because i've been reading her
twitter
and she's so racist she's she's nuts
she's it's not about being racist about
she's an extremist she's an extreme so
listen
what is an extremist everybody will give
you definition i'll give you my simple
definition
a moderate a a a a pragmatist a stoic
rational a leftist a right-wing
individual are not necessarily
extremists
a leftist will say something like i
believe in universal health care and
you know uh workers working worker
control of the means of production to
varying degrees
let's have a conversation about
implementing this a free market
capitalist or an endcap is not an
extremist they'll say
i believe in the free market let's have
a conversation about moving that
direction
what people like corey bush say is expel
all of the republicans who
dared speak up you know uh in defense of
donald trump
that's extremism an extremist says we
must have communism by any means
necessary that's extreme
she is very very extreme yeah it hurts
pin tweet is expel the republican
members of congress who incited the
white supremacist
attempted coup that's insane and so you
know what's funny
is they like to rag on the q anon
members of congress or whatever and i'm
like sure
but show not now complain about the
extremist conspiracy conspiracist
democrats they're there there's no white
supremacist conspiracy going on it's not
real but they live in a paranoid
delusional state
and the media props it up there's
probably there's a class conspiracy
where people
very wealthy people want to stay wealthy
and they're okay with leaving poor
people poor
there is that that does exist well it's
always been about that but they
they and then they they bring the racism
element in to keep
the lower socioeconomic statuses
fighting amongst each other instead of
looking at where the actual problem
because the only oppression
is socioeconomic oppression you know in
this country yeah of course
you're gonna have your outliers but the
majority of people don't experience
racism on a daily basis
but even if you look at the institutions
that cause pain
suffering poverty inequality it's not
your neighbor that believes in a
different political opinion than you
it's a larger institution that's telling
you the problem is your dna
your melatonin that's the issue right
there
yeah and and they convinced people that
somehow this is justified which is
absolutely ridiculous it's insane and
it's driving us down a slippery slope
where we're we are fighting each other
instead of realizing
the bigger picture right in front well
it's it was conveniently around occupy
wall street yeah i was just thinking
that yeah we
we we've talked about it quite a bit the
bankers were were packing their bags
they were ready they were like the jig
is up they're gonna
they're gonna audit the federal reserve
we're done warren buffett was giving
away a ton of
giving away i'll do air quote son of
money mark zuckerberg donate i'm doing
air quotes tons of money
and it wasn't because they had a change
of heart in like the grinch his heart
grew you know three sizes that day was
because they were like
when the pitchforks come out it's coming
for us conveniently people like mark
zuckerberg
who are in control of social media
started feeding identity politics to
everybody
and then there are people who don't like
being insulted based on race
and there are people who like consulting
based on race and boy did they whip them
into a ludicrous friend there was a
little bit of of like racist or identity
politics at occupy and then like the
news organization oh that's good get
that
get that white guy says something
something about black guy put
run with that one well they've always
seen it and you don't see because
no no it's because these i think it's
more a generational thing i don't think
it was necessarily like a rich guy
snapped his fingers and said you know
aha identity politics is a solution
i think it's that this millennial
younger millennial generation
have been raised into this cult probably
going you know influenced very heavily
by colleges
and now they believe an insane cult-like
dogma that
doesn't make sense at all in the middle
east
they try to make us afraid of brown
people with this stupid
muslim attack in the middle east it was
all about let's go after the muslims
like 911 the afghanis iraq it's the
muslims
there's this muslim fear a scapegoat
it's always a scapegoat yeah you can
always just follow that all the way back
you can follow that to germany you can
follow that to the russians
but everybody look even even trump was
was was finding his
target you know audience and what he was
concerned about current concerned about
you know immigration is a problem
islamic terror is a problem and people
were scared of these things
and so he used them my issue is that
they say donald trump is a is a
uh what did they say he was uh what's
the word i'm thinking of i i can't think
of the word
a lot of words demagogue he was choosing
and singling out these people as the
problem i'm like
so are you you you you crazy crazy
people the hypocrisy of the
of the left never ends i mean that's
that's that's their calling card is
is they double standard yeah they'll
call you out on it and then they'll do
the exact same thing
in the next sentence i know the problem
is when trump would say something
like we're gonna have a muslim ban in
this country and they're like ah he
admitted it
and then he like changed it so that
there's like there's actually other
countries in the band it was a
recommendation from the obama
administration republicans
criticize him you got you you get you
get criticism from various republicans
being like i don't agree with donald
trump how dare he say these things
and the left meanwhile does literally
the same thing and
no one calls them out they don't break
ranks no they don't the right does all
the time
dude people were so afraid of muslims in
like two thousand yeah
they were yep that's deep in the
psychology of the
of the people that are 20 years old
today they were born into it like it was
normal oh now they're running for
congress and like making these weird
laws and there's this reverse racism
stuff
well no no the people who are scared of
muslims aren't the left
i don't know who it is anymore it was
all of us i mean i wasn't
no no the left of the people who heard
you saying that right now and we're like
i have to stop these nazi republicans
who hate muslims
they hear you saying that and they grow
up thinking if only i could stop the
racists we're like the multi
with racism right with with worse racism
yeah that that's that's the best part of
it is their solution is always the
problem in and of itself
yeah the house is on fire quick throw
fuel into it we used to turn it down
completely we would like sit at taco
bell as teenagers and talk about reverse
racism we talk about like um
there's no such thing as i know there's
not and it's just racist
there was when i was a kid i was like
okay affirmative action is allowing
just black people to get jobs that
they're not qualified for
so that's a form of reverse racism
against hold on hold on hold on and we
would get so
angry about it no no no no hold on
that's not affirmative action i got
in the 90s was that not affirmative
action is not that someone who's not
qualified is getting a job they would
give it based on race and not quite not
qualifications
they would they would move down the the
list of qualified people until they
found a certain race
certain quote there there are certain
quotas oh yeah yeah so yours was a
little little harsh
in doing that and doing that bypassing
you you run open the or you you open up
the possibility that you will skip
somebody
who is more qualified because you have a
quota to meet so it's
it's it's a side effect of of what
it's what's a good i mean i think that
policy comes from a good place
but it's one of those things that it
sounds better as an idea
and you can't execute it without well
look the the path to hell is paid with
good intentions you know always
so so here's the way it would work let's
save 100 people and they all take a
natchex exam
and the top 10 are mostly white people
because the united states is mostly
white
they would say okay the one two okay
white person white person white person
okay we're going to skip all these
where's the first
latino ah there we go seven he gets the
first slot
so now you've skipped six qualified
individuals in fact
more qualified because you want to have
a race in
you know a particular race in your
system i know now that because of
slavery
a lot of african americans were dumped
into our economy with zero
and so there was this higher wealth uh
bracket for the the people that weren't
african-american you know
lighter-skinned
but and so they're more educated by
because of the the autonomy
i know that now but don't forget the end
of slavery wasn't the end of the
problems
because they were like the the south
after the civil war
didn't want to be occupied by the north
so
they did everything in their power to
obstruct the the 13th 14th 15th
amendments
the right to vote there absolutely was
tons of racist policies
all the way up into jim crow and the
civil rights era and that was all the
democrats mind you
which is kind of funny and now the same
political party
that pushed racism is pushing racism
again today do you think we'll get
past maybe this is kind of an open
question that we'll get past the racism
when we stop listening to politicians
yeah i think your average everyday
person doesn't give
a fish what color you are i think i
think that's a pretty broad statement
but i think that applies to most people
and i think that the fairest statement
ever ever said about trump was that he
doesn't care
whether you're white black latino gay
straight he cares if you can make him
money
to clarify you you said ship like you
know a vessel on
water correct yeah yeah okay very very
good
but but it's too much race is too much
of an effective
divider uh by the elites that that's
been working for them very well and as
you said sp
if people stop paying attention to all
the people
pushing it on us and actually being
racist i think then it could finally
work and i think
there's a very small window but it's one
of the biggest effective battering
battering rams against the populations
from actually realizing that they have a
lot more in common
than they do could we potentially end on
a positive note and talk about what's
happening in tunisia holland and denmark
with all the protests
as well as the bigger movements in italy
and poland the mass
riots and mass arrests well on a
positive note showing that you know in
in italy and poland
there's people coming together and
saying enough of these lockdowns we're
going to open up in unison where there's
too many of us where you can't shut us
all down
i think that's a positive step and uh
regarding what's happening in denmark
there's been a lot of protests
against the lockdowns uh that that are
huge but yet have not garnered a lot of
media attention which which is why i
think we should talk about them
on a kind of lighter more positive note
that there is some kind of
you wanna you wanna you wanna talk
positive you know we're going to have to
like
try hard to find a story from the news
outlet mom because look even if we want
to be positive about what's going on
with coveted
the story we have here from dw from uh
about tunisia
600 people arrested the army has been
deployed after violent protests these
people are frustrated over what's going
on the lockdowns
and so they're coming out and the
state's coming out and beating 600
people that's a massive arrest
in the netherlands 142 people got
arrested so
sure i guess there's an optimism there's
a hope people are starting to say
enough of this standing up and saying it
didn't work
it's not working and we will not suffer
any longer
that's good that you know it gives me
hope when i see people standing up for
what they believe in
it is but there's a crackdown from the
state across the board
and i don't i don't know if we have any
reason to believe that they're going to
give in to the demands of these angry
individuals
yes but we can't give up all hope and i
think when we
see these issues we have to cover them
honestly and fairly
so maybe my wording wasn't the best in
in that particular instant and involved
a lot of personal stuff from what i've
seen throughout last year and what's
unfolding this year but but you know
talking about your story you're still
kicking you're still pushing forward and
and i think
i think you should answer this question
more than me since of course
you're still fighting the fight rather
than us
just kind of calling it and observing it
i
i am optimistic actually you know i i've
i've been doing this alongside my
partner frank for eight months now
you know we opened on may 18th you know
so
pretty much eight months to the day um
and there is a growing sense of
rebellion
and a growing sense of defiance
from everybody um
you know when we first opened up we had
a ton of support
more support than we ever imagined but
it was mainly from the right
it was mainly trump supporters it was
mainly
conservatives libertarians you know
constitutionalists
that support as this has gone on has
intensified with those people but also
broadened
um the people you know when we first
opened who just really weren't
interested in the story or
didn't think it was that important at
the time started to get involved
and then as this has continued to draw
out
we've gotten a lot of support from
people who are typically moderate lefts
and even people who identify a little
bit
you know harder to the left i i tell the
story a lot i had a guy come into the
to the gym bought a t-shirt and um you
know i'm packing it up for him and i
said thank you for your support
and he uh he looked at me and he said i
want you i want to be honest with you
and i said sure he said in the beginning
of this
i thought you and frank were
wrong you know to to say it nicely he
didn't say it so nicely
um he said i thought you guys were
greedy i thought you were doing it for
your own selfish reasons
i thought you were you were being
careless um and i
and and you really pissed me off and he
said the only reason i followed the
story was because
you really pissed me off and he said i
trash talk to you online
you know any any negative article i
could find i would share it i would
you know argue in your comment section
and he said i'm here today because i've
i've watched
this continue for five months now or
whatever it was
and he said i support you he said and
i'm still a democrat
you know he said he said i think at the
time he said i'm still going to vote for
biden
he said but what's happening to you is
not okay
he said and i disagree with it and and
that is just continuing to grow and grow
and grow
to where i think it's it's scary because
i think we're gonna see
more of that that you're seeing in
tunisia where
people are are gonna start hitting their
their capacity
for being pushed around and you can only
say please mr politician let me open my
business please mr politician
let me go back to work please mr
politician i need a stimulus check more
than 600
please mr politician don't send 700
billion
overseas we need it here before people
start getting increasingly frustrated
and that's
that that's a pandora's box you know
you're gonna
open something where change is gonna
happen one way or another
um and it it's it's probably not gonna
be as
a smooth change you know you're gonna
see some some bumpy
occurrences during that but i think the
people who are frustrated are in the
right
and i think that they do have a right to
be and i wish that there was a better
way to
to settle it um i wish everybody would
just do what they're doing in italy
you know and and what we did you know we
we opened
we're open no matter what no matter what
you do to us
we are going to open unless we are in
jail we are opening and as soon as we
get out we're going to open again
that's been our plan from day one and if
everybody does that
and doesn't get extreme and doesn't get
violent and doesn't get destructive
then we win and it's it is that simple
because there aren't enough jail sales
there aren't enough sheriffs there
aren't enough handcuffs there aren't
enough squad cars for everybody
and it's a house of cards it's an
illusion based on fear
it's fear and control and as soon as
everybody turns off the tv
stops listening to the politicians and
says enough is enough it's over they
can't enforce it yeah do you know what
started the
arab spring no there was a
fruit vendor who was being just harassed
by cops told he couldn't
sell his fruit they would confiscate his
fruit and he just wanted to run his
little f
fruit vendor business but they wouldn't
let him so one day he went in front of a
government building and he lit himself
on fire
and then the whole country this is
tunisia erupted
into mass rioting which swept across
north africa into the middle east
and removed some dictators
all because the government because a
couple cops would not let some guy just
run his business
i think it's fair to say what we're
going through right now is sort of a
information war or or a larger consensus
war and once you lose hope
you essentially lose that's why i'm
always personally cheering on the
underdog and maybe that's why i'm i'm
not unbiased it is a biased perspective
where i come from
sometimes but at least i acknowledge it
and i think more of us
should be willing to do that especially
when it comes to kind of calling these
larger
things that are happening right now
because information is key and it could
lead to a lot of amazing
incredible developments but once you try
to
censor once you try to close down this
kind of wider highway of speech
that's really when we get into very
troubling territories of people
using and abusing it against the weakest
and the smallest in our society
and hurting them tremendously and that's
why when you're doing something that's
helping people get healthy
helping people work out get in a
position where their immune system is
activated and then you're the one that's
being targeted
you're the one that they're trying to
take down it's just ridiculous and i
know
and and then i know they took away your
money but there's also i don't know if
you want to get into this or or talk
about this there's also other
alternatives with cryptocurrencies
i don't know if you want to personally
talk about that or not and i respect
your decision either way
yeah no that's it it's this whole thing
has been
just a game of kind of staying on our
feet you know it's
when you take on city hall it's a
12-round fight and it's it's
it's the 12-round rocky story where
you're gonna get your face bashed in
for 11 rounds straight and all you got
to do is stay on your feet
long enough to get to the end to where
you inspire enough people
um and and you've made enough of a
splash and an
impact that it's a domino effect and and
you get to the end because all it takes
is that you know in the rocky store it
takes that
that one you know bob and weave and that
one good punch
and you can take the whole thing down
but it's
it's not falling into the traps that
they're gonna set for you and they
they want that they want the violence
they want the unrest they want people to
go crazy
because then they can say look at them
look look at these crazy people over
here
and that's that that's what happened at
the capitol
you know whether we have all the details
or not that's
that's and they'll use that against you
so it's you have to stay calm and you
have to stay optimistic you know so
that's been that's been my saving grace
all the way through that and i have a
lot i have a lot of people behind me who
who reinforce that quite a bit
because it is a frustrating experience
when you're dealing with somebody
who is actively undermining and ruining
your life
the best thing is to just take continue
to take the high road and and
that's been our strategy all the way
through so crypto is just
the next thing for us you know we've
we've done everything we possibly can
and we've we will continue to exhaust
every single resource
without stepping into that trap that
they want
you know so yeah crypto crypto has been
a good option for us and it's going to
be
the way we we move forward in the future
to protect ourselves from from more
oversight i mean excuse me more
overreach
that's an excellent endorsement of why
cryptocurrencies are so powerful
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you